welcome back to cbs mornings the drought
in the west has become so severe that
the federal government has declared the
colorado river water shortage to be the
worst on record
now that triggers automatic cuts to the
water supply for arizona and nevada too
and the government is now threatening
unprecedented cuts for all the states to
draw water from the river unless unless
they start using less
ben tracy visited lake powell one of the
largest reservoirs on the colorado river
to see the toll that this mega drought
is taking
we're going to buoy number three they
call it paul mcnabb and his dad mike are
fishing guides on utah's lake powell
they've been casting along these canyons
for decades they caught one they're
worried that the wall in front of their
favorite fishing hole will just keep
getting taller i'm looking at spots that
30 40 feet up the wall where my bait was
hitting where i was fishing just a year
ago so you're saying literally a year
ago this boat we're on right now would
have been 30 40 feet up there yep yep
it's absolutely crazy how much it's come
down
at one point lake powell had dropped
nearly 40 feet in just one year these
satellite images show how quickly it has
shriveled up during a 22 year long mega
drought as climate change makes the west
hotter and drier this massive reservoir
is now just 25 percent full that white
bathtub ring is where the water was
before the drought began
166 feet higher than it is now if the
lake continues to keep going down at the
rate that it is it's it's pretty scary
situation what do you predict about the
future of this business you got
i would say that we got five years left
and then your business is done yep
houseboats are already running out of
room
ten of lake powell's 12 boat ramps are
closed because they can't reach the
water if the lake keeps falling the glen
canyon dam won't be able to produce
hydropower impacting the electricity
supply for more than 5 million people in
six states
in april the assistant secretary of the
interior warned western governors of
profound concerns in operating the dam
at lower lake levels and that the
western electrical grid would experience
uncertain risk and instability well i'm
very concerned brian hill is general
manager of page utilities the arizona
town used to get 50 percent of its
electricity from the dam that's been cut
in half as lake levels have fallen
for all the southwest i think the
situation is critical so mother nature
is going to have to come to the rescue
or we're going to have to really look at
some different ways of how we use water
throughout the southwest
lake powell is considered a savings
account banking excess water and then
sending it down the colorado river to
lake mead the nation's largest reservoir
this river system supplies water for 40
million people in the west
in an unprecedented move the federal
government is holding back most of the
water that would have been sent down
river and propping up lake powell with
water from reservoirs upriver it is a
band-aid fix and everybody knows it
eric balkin runs the glen canyon
institute named for the massive canyon
that was flooded to create lake powell
back in the 1960s after the dam was
built at this moment
lake powell was born
before the dam was in place glen canyon
was considered one of the most
remarkable
landscapes in the u.s people who knew it
well considered it to be as beautiful as
the grand canyon seeing this place come
back to life is just such a special
experience now as the water recedes the
lost treasures of glen canyon are
re-emerging this is just stunning in
here
it's a very special place balkan took us
into what's known as cathedral in the
desert a massive cavern of undulating
rock and a trickling waterfall
so that part of the chamber has not been
seen since the 1960s when we were here
last year
we were parking our boats right here
and now one of the largest natural
bridges in the country has risen out of
the water this bridge was covered by
water so what we're boating under you
used to be able to boat over he used to
be able to boat over the top of this
bridge and you think we'll be hiking
under here i think we'll be hiking under
here probably in the next few years this
is amazing it's like a dead forest
coming out of the water yeah yeah we
call them ghost forests forests once
drowned on the canyon floor are
reappearing new plants and trees are
starting to grow nearby
and balkan says ancient footholds from
indigenous people who climbed here more
than a thousand years ago can now be
seen as more and more of these
incredible one-of-a-kind features come
out of water there's no reason they
shouldn't be protected
balkan wants glen canyon to become a
national park part of a movement to
drain lake powell and fill up lake mead
since both reservoirs are at critically
low levels the purpose of the reservoir
was to store excess water and we're in a
place now where excess water is a thing
of the past the rate of change that
we're seeing now is happening way faster
than i ever thought it would
which is startling in some ways but it
also gives me a lot of hope because
we're seeing so much come back
because right now this is both a
reservoir on life support
and a lost canyon being reborn
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in big
water utah
those images are stunning yeah they're
actually very beautiful but
we're not supposed to be able to see
them that's what's so upsetting about it
yeah we shouldn't even be able to look
at that very haunting backstory 40
million people depending on that water
it keeps going lower and lower 10 of 12
boat drops are shut down the ramps are
not usable because the water has receded
that much think about that and tony hugh
believes that we'll be able to hike
under it that's that's not good when i
when our environment starts to yell at
us and whisper to us exactly we need to
pay pay attention that's for sure